as the rain arrived over london it fell
on a small but growing group huddled on
the south bank of the river thames
waiting with still more than a day to go
before they'd be able to file past the
queen's coffin first in line vanessa had
been here since monday and think that
i'm going to be the first one out of the
public and it is this mixed feelings
saying prayers in our hearts
great lady to
peacefully rest this is something very
small
you know considering that she spent 70
years
looking after us making big sacrifices
you know doing a great job are you
worried about what's going to happen
overnight the slightest i'm english
we're used to the weather it can hail
stones snow
hurricanes i'm staying here
hundreds of thousands are expected to
line up during the four days in which
the queen will lie in state
their speed and numbers will be
monitored closely officials say they may
decide to stop new arrivals for the sake
of safety
and when this cue finally does get
underway it will proceed up and over
lambeth bridge across the river thames
along the north bank past the houses of
parliament to westminster hall and
officials are warning that those
especially those waiting on the south
bank stretching back will be here for a
very long time in a constantly moving
queue with few opportunities to have a
rest
it will be here at westminster hall that
members of the public will have their
long-awaited private moment
a short walk away in green park more
private tributes and memories inscribed
amid the flowers from witnessing the
coronation woke up at six o'clock in the
morning my sandwiches and my dad took me
up there
and my flag could save the queen
and my mum was crying with excitement
because i got picked out to see the
queen to a wedding at the same edinburgh
cathedral where this week the queen lay
at rest very sad very poignant
we know exactly where her
her casket is i mean that's we literally
were standing there to be married
for so many a constant presence in their
daily life is no more and whether with
flowers messages or patient queuing it's
being marked harry fawcett al jazeera
london